hi my name is Schmitz for the
who i am i'm the director of the yale
institute for biospheric studies I was
actually going to finish this symposium
with a talk on how impressionistic art
the dynamism that comes from that has
informed and inspired my my science but
I think given the lateness of the hour
and the adage less is more I think we'll
end here I just wanted to explain sort
of the background real briefly though
the impetus for this was really the
recognition that on my board I had
numerous artists and yet the EBEs board
actually focuses and nibs itself focuses
a lot more on the environmental sciences
and not so much on the humanist side and
I said you know maybe there's a way that
we can engage some of these board
members to actively participate in in
dialogue and and and and thinking about
how we can extend Gibbs's impact at Yale
and and and try and broaden its horizons
a little bit and I'm hoping this is
going to be a nice springboard for more
education at Yale in terms of blending
the humanities and the Natural Sciences
and really have the the interactive
dialogues that we really need to to
inspire maybe new science or do
different ways that we do our science or
even how we might inspire new kinds of
art i'd like to thank james and
elizabeth Sidman erised off me sort of
think this through and they were the
ones who organized this so let's give
them a hand of thanks
a great round of thanks to all our
speakers who have given us wonderful
ideas and different ways of looking at
things
and just wanted to point out a lot of
James's paintings that he showed here
are actually hung up on the walls in
here so and please enjoy them when
you're when you're going to the
reception but the other thing that I'd
like to point out is James has kindly
allowed us to auction those those
paintings these are limited edition of
one he will sign them it'll be a silent
auction the clipboards are there if you
would like to put a bid on this and it
is intended as a fundraiser we'd like to
do a mini conference next fall on
biodiversity science and conservation
and we would use those funds to help
support that mini conference so thank
you for attending and please enjoy the
reception that's to follow here